please welcome elana glazers
so much thank you so much thank you
i went full jewish disney princess for
you
i was like drew's gonna like this
i was such a fan and um i was lucky
enough to see some moments uh where i
actually my name is said in the show and
i was so
happy
oh drew barrymore
[Applause]
hi
that is so funny
oh my god this is the bag
that i wrote the article about that's so
funny and also like i have two wheelie
burton bags because abby got them
because you had them
in real life and what's upsetting is
they don't make this bag anymore and i
just want to demonstrate as the article
says okay so
so okay first of all it's made my burton
surfboard so it's a wet wetsuit material
so we all know how great that is uh
skateboard wheels and wow
and then the reason that i love this
suitcase so much
is because i literally put my entire
house in here but look oh my god
wait this is not the model that i have
and i kind of want to sit in it get in
there if i didn't have the dress
i'm like i can fully sit in here
oh my god
it's such an honor you're so
generous and sweet this is so
i can't tell you what a surreal cool
moment is when you're watching something
you love
and then you like
drift through it it's so surreal well
yeah and it's it's also like um in your
life oh you're getting out oh
i thought you were getting out i was
just like sort of adjusting um because i
was pretty comfortable but uh look at
this everybody
okay well you are a mom now and you like
now what is your journey how are you
liking it i'm loving it it's like ugh
you know i guess i'm like i want to
touch on people have postpartum
depression and that's normal and
struggles in this way which i totally
is important to talk about but my
experience
i'm a cow because i'm breastfeeding i'm
really hurt
i'm really just a little coward i'm this
little baby's cow she's like milking me
milking me milk on me um
but she
my husband is the milkmaid i love it oh
my god it's also so cute and true and
you do feel like that but i've had a
like a uh just sort of
lucky smooth road
just a luckily smooth road so far
pregnancy there wasn't anything major
but i was so sick during while shooting
the after party but it was like funny
because nothing was wrong so i was like
lol i'm puking all the time it was just
kind of funny it's so funny because
you're like you you can't you're not pro
how pregnant were you because i was like
looking at your body and you look hot
you're in a mini skirt
a little bolero jacket
and
i was i was so hot i was showing in the
boobs my belly pops like at the end um
okay so you were doing the after party
and it was in the pandemic
yeah um
in a safe when it became safe to do
something like this and then you guys
must have been a serious pod but what a
pod
yeah what a pod it was like
these are like the funniest people in
the game right now all in one show john
early tiffany haddish ben schwartz sam
richardson
calvin hughes zoe chao de franco tia
serkar jamie dimitru genevieve unjulson
that is it's such a strong group of
comedians and
i got so excited and why i love you and
abby so much as i need comedy i need it
in my life it's one of the things i want
to celebrate
most in this show is the adoration and
admiration of comedians and by the way
aren't you on a text chain
with a lot of comedians yes well the
after party thread it's like i'm like
trying to like pitch jokes on this text
thread it's like really um it's tough to
get in there they're they're such a
funny bunch i would say kelvin you is
one to look out for he's winning the
text thread really he's winning the text
thread you're gonna love him in the show
if you haven't seen it yet and is it
true
that your dad
helped you when broad city because this
is also something else that i really
appreciated knowing is people don't want
they don't talk a lot about um
how scary it is to do stand-up and when
people see something that is such a
success like broad city
was it always and if it wasn't how did
it function that's so funny like i think
the well i don't know but the best
things come out of failures i think the
biggest wins come out of failures like
abby and i couldn't get could not get
cast onto like the in-house teams at the
improv theater that we were that we met
at um that's why we started broad city i
love this so
much i asked johnny knoxville i'm like
because he was offered a role on
saturday night live and he
took the risk and didn't do it and he
took the uncertain road to be with his
friends and be their authentic selves
um wow i did not know that that's
shocking i know
and that also it's like people are like
the power of yes yes yes more more and
more but the power of no is and
resisting for him to pass on that that
is like that's a different kind of um
strength i don't know if i have a lot of
power of now me neither i am such a yes
man me too me too i love to say yes and
be the person saying yes but it's like
not always right okay we'll be back uh
with more from alana don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
[Music]